get started we're a little bit late but
welcome everybody glad that you're here
and again just to make sure that just
for the sake of being able to hear each
other that when you're not speaking or
we're not entertaining questions or
hearing from growers at your location if
you please hit the mute button
facilitators that would be awesome okay
so this is our second annual put a video
conference focusing as transitioning to
reduced tillage I have a PowerPoint that
I mean and I'm assuming that you're the
powerpoint that you guys can see that if
you cannot see it please let us know all
right now move to just basically a quick
overview again of what our effort has
focused on we have been focusing for the
last several years on really trying to
help growers increase the use of reduced
tillage in their vegetable operation so
our effort numbered northeastern cooler
areas of the Northeast and we've been
focusing our research and education
efforts with growers on overcoming basic
challenges that we know exists and we're
trying to overcome them looking at weed
management issues dealing with soil
quality soul compaction ensuring that we
can actually get timely harvest of the
crops that were growing dealing with
pests and good looking at harvest
strategies there's two issues for
processing crops that we've had
conversations around the other area of
work that we have and that we have
continuous had developed and identify
equipment or strategies that are all
scales so much there's a lot of
equipment out there it's available for
larger operations that can handle the 4
/ 6 from higher than that now but
dealing with decimal real operation pipe
so we consider trying to work growers if
you can use that are appropriate test
you
and then finally we wanna we continue to
work to do demonstrations on farm and on
station we've got basically a really
exciting collaboration how that go
across the Northeast to really test and
make make some of these demonstrations
available to growers so they can
actually look and see how our crops
performing so one thing that I wanted to
do is to highlight really quickly some
of the work that's going on we just got
funded recently by northeast air and the
focus is to look at Gaeseong village
which we're going to talk a lot about
today to try to actually address a
particularly difficult test by Kapler
caps to see and our reason for taking
this on and looking at this is that we
believe that the soil management and
salt all the improvements in doing deep
zone tilton will actually reduce the
speed of the development of the disease
in fields that are infected and and so
we have Charles that are going on on
farms have a history of the disease and
we are looking for more collaborators
for this coming year but what we want to
do is to be able to look at both we have
on station trials at research firms
Weaver thought we do have research firms
at half italic app see and in fact I've
cultivated in some ways but we also then
doing Charles on-farm over three years
where we set up fields that are paired
with deep zone tillage and then their
traditional conventional tillage
whatever you might be using and on those
fields we want to actually look at soil
moisture soil water management changes
in the amount of saturation that we see
in fields and then eventually with a
susceptible crop see if we actually do
delay the onset of pcap and so that
people can harvest for a longer period
in those years we might have a conducive
sort of moisture conditions for the
development of the disease so if you are
interested and I put this out there now
so as we go through the day and we have
these conversations around equipment and
management and other issues that if you
are interested in collaborating with us
we would welcome that we are looking
growers that have fields with a district
by Toffler captaincy and you'd have to
complete like to have two fields on any
farm so that we know that there's
different rotations that people are
using at this time and so we want to be
able to set up fields where we do zone
tillage in part and conventional when
the others and the goal is that over the
next few years that you're working with
us that you do grow a susceptible crop
in these fields at least once so that we
can actually look at the disease onset
and that we ourselves the team will
actually be at your firm and doing soil
health test looking at soil health soul
quality water infiltration soil moisture
retention and other aspects of how this
system affects soils in those particular
fields and as part of that we want to be
able to get a sense from all of you who
are doing these Charles as to are you
some other benefits until around labor
hours practice management overall
impressions with the system in addition
particular in New York we have funding
to help offset some of the cost to set
up a trial so if you don't have this
equipment but you want to try zone
tillage we have some funding from both
New York farm viability we were
reinstated with our funding with that
group for one year and at least for one
more year we're not sure what the status
is of the New York farm viability
Institute but we do hope that they
continue to receive funding to help
growers in agriculture New York but
between farm viability and the New York
State specialty crop research initiative
we have cost share funds and these funds
can be used as sort of supplement and
help lower the cost of renting equipment
depending on the size is certainly if
you're 40 or if you can handle for rural
equipment you would look at renting from
a dealer and we have a network of
dealers around the state that are
willing to work with you and we can help
pay for some of the transportation costs
the rental costs and then the per acre
costs that they charge or if you have
smaller system we colonel have several
different units that Arturo that we have
available for use on farms and then
Long Island and in Western in eastern
New York there are also two road units
are available I just wanted to make that
aware make you aware of it if you're
interested in working with us and doing
a trial or setting up a trial definitely
contact your local Extension educator
because they would be the ones to help
facilitate this and then we could get
sort of talk with you about how to set
up one of these trials on your farm so
this is just a picture of one of the
units of Jim capron who's in western New
York helped us build this unit and the
objective of this trial unit is to allow
you to do some deep placement of
nitrogen or if you're using conventional
dry fertilizer you can put this on it's
two row only but it is set up to
actually do some fertilizer placement
experiments we're also building a very
small lighter weight unit that that will
work with smaller tractors and this is
using a yeoman's plow these plows were
developed in New Zealand for managing
moisture water on pastures but they
create the same kind of disturbance
fracturing deep soul that's compacted in
creating a nice area that's worked for
planting in order for direct seeding or
transplanting vegetables and then we
also have a two rows own builder that we
have taken two different farms around
the state to help them set up trials and
tests deep zone tillage and this is a
picture of the unit that's in eastern
New York that Chuck port has and I know
growers have used and used this trial
unit for doing demonstrations so with
that I just want to make sure that
you're aware of the website where we
have case studies and other information
previous people's experiences from
trying zone collect on their farms and
vegetables and again we are really
focused on vegetables I know we get a
lot of folks coming that do field crops
as well and that's great but we don't
talk about them too much um and so with
that I basically just wanted to give you
an overview and a highlight as far as
the next part of our agenda we wanted to
be able to move into a conversation on
equipment and
have a chance for growers to learn and
share from each other about different
equipment that they're using and what
their experiences have been let's eat do
you have a copy and and so for this part
of it we do actually have we do have a
PowerPoint that if and we have some
pictures that we can put up based on it
throwers have anything specific that
they want to be talking about around
their equipment and then after that
point at ten o'clock we'll have to break
and then we're going to bring Thomas you
Bjorkman in to talk a little bit more
specifically uncover crops and the
tillage radish she's been a lot of
growers interested in tillage radish and
so we want to have the Pens to talk
about that some cover crops and how we
integrate cover crops into these found
tillage systems and then we're going to
focus in on weed management issues there
are some specific questions that growers
have generated that we asked Richmond on
to address for us and I'm he and Robin
bolander have been talking about some of
these issues so he'll be talking to us
about that and then we'll come back at
the end on more experiences related to
fertility management that growers have
been using different strategies so again
we're connected this morning together
and so it's a chance for us to be able
to learn across these different
locations I'll learn from growers in
other parts of the region as to what's
working and what's not for them we're
going to add when we break for lunch we
are happy to buy you lunch today but we
do encourage you afterwards is that we
want to have time and local discussions
both if you want to participate in these
trials and work with us to do
demonstrations or to actually get
involved with the fight after
experiments please do think about that
and talk with educator about that but
also we want to have a global
discussions and what do we need to know
what other research questions or other
issues need to be addressed to help
growers take up these systems and we
need feedback from you as you think
about how you might apply these on your
own farm
and then also we have a short evaluation
that we're asking you to take for us all
of this work is funded by grants and
they always want to know how are we
doing and what are we learning our our
what else do we need to do our focus you
should work on so with that what i might
i'd like to do is I'll quickly check in
with folks if there's any questions
about anything I've said or any
questions about the agenda how I'll do
that is I'll go second sight so let's
start with Carol and western New York
are there any any questions before we
get started on the equipment sections
Carol what questions before we start
looking at it and discussing equipment
no nope all right you all right how
about new mass uh Andy anybody have
questions so far looks like we're good
all right um how about Long Island we're
good okay and Jeff no questions here I
do have one question related to the
PowerPoint that was sent with all the
equipment is that something that you'd
like us to show before we have that
general discussion or not um that
PowerPoint has pictures that growers may
refer to in the discussion and so that's
why we sent it along so you could
actually have something to look up okay
thank you sure all right